yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby it's
a good day buddy it's a good day it's a
we got two things going on we got baby
came home baby well not yet baby we got
the okay where uh we can go pick her up
so baby's out of the hospital thank good
dear sweet Lord takes a long time you
get that call right shout out to the
Nick unit at Cedar cyanide they are
angels they are angels of kiddos doctors
and the nurses y they're the absolute
best of the best so shout out to them so
I'm so excited for the baby girl to come
home it's always nerve-wracking when you
bring a newborn home it's going to be a
little different yeah plan of action
here and then the Lightning's not a
lemon so we have both Lightning's not a
lemon Lightning's not a lemon lightning
not a lemon Lightning's not a lemon took
it to the specialist Eddie addiction
Motorsports yeah you know when you don't
know somebody they jump in you know and
I was like trying you know I don't know
him so I was like hey man so how long
you been doing this and he go just jump
in and he's like let me drrive drive it
let me feel what's going on here he's
been doing it forever yeah and so it's
all quiet and I was like so how long you
been doing this he's like sh sh the [__]
up for a second and I was like oh okay
that's weird he goes it's your fuel pump
and your spark plugs are misfiring no
and I was like you think he's like I
would bet my last dollar he's like who
told you it was the transmission or the
twerk he's like no the transmission you
would know would be slipping he goes I
go well yeah but let's get it like on
your machine say again say again it's
your fuel pump and spark plugs misfiring
dude that's a dude who knows a sh sets
it up he's like look look at the
pressure gauge on the fuel pump he's
like so I told you we need a new we need
to replace the fuel pump and then we'll
just get the new spark plug just things
up and running and he's like oh and you
B think it was stock he go no no no
throttle bodies all custom the intake
the pulleys the headers the exhaust he's
like this is all he's like the whole
suspension's been redone man I love
people like that who are that who are
expert at their field they they seem
psychic but they can just pick up on on
[__] oh dude was literally driving going
sh just shut the [__] up for a second
God really he's going FL and he Flo he's
first of all he's driving with his eyes
cloes for 3 seconds I'm like
uh he floors it and he goes he goes fuel
pump damn I know and then I was like you
worked on he's like all the time that so
there was a a saleswoman in New York
City they wrote an article about her I
never forgot this they used to sell you
know what a Steinway piano is it's the
most expensive piano it's like handmade
it's the Bentley of piano yeah and so if
you're a concert pianist you play
Steinway this woman had been selling
steinways for so long she was a piano
player herself now every Steinway sounds
different it's just got its own
temperament and she to a person could
see somebody walk into the place she
could look at them the way they were
dressed the way they were talking and
she'd go I know what I know what piano
they're going to choose and they would
do these bets and she would she got it
right got it right every time she just
knew that they were going to have a
temperament that that resonated with
that particular pitch or whatever it was
and every single time and it got so
crazy they thought she was magic that
the New York Times came and did a whole
[__] they actually had reporters there
to see if she could do this and sure
enough she goes well she's gonna that
that woman is going to pick that piano
she's going to play them all she's gonna
pick that one every single people who
are experts like this Eddie and what's
cool about him is you know I'm not a
Gearhead I've never pretended I'm a
Gearhead I can't fix this stuff I don't
it's a different language and he was
cool cuz you know he's so busy like he's
been pretty short on the phone too so
I'm like oh man so I was like scared to
go up there and then he pulled up in
this sick old school Malibu I was like
damn that your right what's up man I'm
Eddie like Co man he's like jump was
like jump in go he's like I'm going for
a ride pulls it in and was like look man
let me show you this is why he's like
look at the spark plug do you see a
difference like literally it was taking
the time swamp was like look see the the
Gap there it's Miss firing there he's
like look let me show you the fuel pump
he's like this is where you locate
that's what you do he's like look at the
pressure should be at here you're at
here so that's how you can tell the
difference he's like let me show you the
the throttle body like went through the
whole thing I'm like holy this guy's
great there are people that can do that
with uh and I was trying to tell him I
was like man I'm so jealous like I wish
I had all that insight and that
knowledge how with cars like you just
how do you know all this you just study
all he's like I just been around cars my
entire life he's grew up in he's grew up
in the shop and then you know you're
taking engines apart you put them
together eventually just know what's
going on with it he's like same thing
like with fighting you're an expert
how'd you get used to that I'm like I
was in gyms he's like same mil was in
garages you're in gyms I don't know what
you know you don't know what I know I
talked to an ER surgeon a guy who would
who would he would you get a gunshot
wound victim somebody's dying right
there they have to stabilize you to go
on the surgery those dudes are the
mechanics so those guys you come in
you're bading you got they he was going
through what he does he goes well I I
stabilize pressure here I close off this
hard it's it's not different than a car
I said to him I go you're like a
mechanic he goes I'm mean I'm that's
exactly what I I'm literally a mechanic
CU if one thing's off then you have
problems over here look at your body
your barometric pressure in your body is
shitty you're going to die I got I got
to stabilize that I got to shut this off
I got to close this off I got to open
this thing yeah I love it too and he's
like all right and I was he was like
we'll get this fixed this is easy just
get these parts and then get it fixed
and my boys at LMR were're like yep what
do you need so they're sending it he's
like all right we'll have it in Monday
it be running he goes this thing with
already with these mods probably over
400 horsepower he's like but what's the
goals I was like like 600 at the wheels
you know and he's like okay and
literally without he was like you're
going have to replace this this this
this otherwise it's going to blow damn I
was like oh no doubt he's like so this
what you need that's what you need I'm
like yeah but should we tell he's like I
don't need tune I I know exactly what
you need to do to reach exactly 600 rear
wheel horsepower that's like that is a
you know what that is he's a master and
there's a there's a theory that when you
learn something when you learn one thing
so well you learn life like the idea is
everything's a fractal of itself like so
the human cell when you really
understand what goes on in the human
cell it's as it's literally as
complicated as the universe like there's
so many that little tiny cell yeah yeah
it's and everything's a fractal of that
like that he's such a beast such a beast
well he's a master met you know what you
met a master you met a you met a a u uh
Jedi but I told him that's why the the
like Auto Community like the truck
Community is so dope everybody in their
mom tagged me to go to him wow cuz I
went to Ford and he was like he's like
Ford wouldn't know cuz they don't he's
like they don't they're they're they
Young kids and they don't know what to
look for they don't have the experience
or they just don't care man like they're
pumping cars out yeah he's like and this
is a 20-year-old car so you got to know
your [__] he's like of course they
thought it was you know the computer
which is the easy swap he's like and
he's like within two minutes of when you
pulled in I knew something was that guy
Gary Brea who saved Dana White's life
Dana White had the highest blood
pressure he said you're going to be dead
in 10 years he's looking at all his
markers and Dana was on all this high
blood pressure med all medication yeah
and you could see his face he looked
like he was about to burst right and
Gary Brea said you can have everything
normal but if you don't know to look for
this particular I guess enzyme or
hormone in the blood then then there is
a certain thing you can take one thing
that will stabilize you but you're
looking at the heart when you have to
look at the other things and he just
knew that everybody everybody all the
doctor everybody's looking over here and
he said you got to look over here they
wouldn't understand this and he's a
biologist and and if you look at Gary
Brea I don't know him but if you look at
his body again like guys like that he's
in great shape he [__] lives what he
talks about and look at Dana Dana looks
what a difference yeah he looks great
godam yeah those experts man good God
like look at them yeah that's scary um
and also like there have been many
critics about Gary bka I'm sure even F
that's
fine that's how it goes to predict like
his death date if he didn't change stuff
but I listened to him on Joe Rogan's
podcast and I was like crap this guy
knows a lot of [__] of course he does
but whenever medical field what whatever
field you're in people are going come
for you sure cuz they have one belief
and they've never experienced this guy
listen Dana could reach out to anybody
in the world he like connect with this
guy this guy got it done okay it works
for Dana yeah [__] off he he's he's been
criticized because some of the stuff he
says may not have uh what is the word
some of the stuff doesn't have um a lot
of research behind it there's no there's
no papers behind it but in his
experience works but but yeah but I will
say that he if you look at his body and
you look at how he is and you look that
he what he did with Dana he's obviously
got case studies where the [__] he does
works oh I would instead of a case study
i' or instead of a regular like research
or study I I see Dana I'm like he's
doing pretty well oh [__] that's enough
for me oh yeah dude I I I go with those
kind of people when I see them put their
money where their mouth is it's like
okay look at our our at our cat I search
Dana White but then this PO cat blowing
up I love it I love it um well that that
that leads like again you don't know
what it's the internet so you don't know
what's real what's not real it's like
with this Ian Gary stuff dude it it's
what is going on right when it came out
so my whole thing with this is when I
saw the tweets and like threatening the
the lawsuit with Strickland if you just
look at the verb it's in the tweets I'm
like that's not in G like in the DMS I'm
like that's not in G the way he's
talking you mean the way he's talking
meaning his wife has taken over as his
PR spare social media spokesman and
she's she's doing a disservice thean
Gary she's not staring down the right
ship it's not good it's not good at
all and then the the the rumors of the
ex-husband living with him I heard it
like that's a troll job and some of the
other stuff is weird but we we have an
expert we're going to reach out to that
my boy Jesse Jesse on fire he he knows
the down low on all this should we call
him so you and I don't sound like idiots
should I call Jesse you can get him on
the phone y not believe it just happened
let's do that first
yeah can I can I see the while he
getting him can I see that Sean
Strickland thing I got him right here
okay be let's take a little break cuz
you're headed to England I'm headed to
Chicago next Friday and Saturday two
shows only on Friday two shows only on
Saturday I'm off to Nashville January
25th Austin January 26 27th where you
going be buddy Bren because I'm goingon
to be in um Indiana December 7th uh 8th
and 9th brian.com for Texas to
Indianapolis at Helium then span Comedy
Club December 15 and 16 then the
following week off the hook Comedy Club
December 21 22 lot of dates dude yeah
every every weekend in December and I'm
ringing in near in Charlotte North
Carolina man let talk about diversifying
your portfolio you got a financial
portfolio you can't put all your eggs in
one basket it's a good way to get broke
you talking about gold right now dude
gold has always been SC MC duck Scrooge
McDuck is my hero and I tried copying
how he jumps into the coins almost broke
my neck now you can because gold has
always held its value I don't care if
you
back now yeah I'm talking about a
company called goldco that's rated A
Plus by the Better Business Bureau
they've got over 5,000 fstar reviews
they're are seven time Inc 5000 winner
um and uh basically they right now are
offering up to $10,000 in bonus silver
if you use our promo code at Gold
code.com
fighter and that's where you can also
learn more about how to diversify your
portfolio that's gold code.com fighter
get your scro mic.com
look man dude macadamia nuts might be
the best nut you can eat for longevity
they're so tasty heal the prom they're
so freaking expensive well House of
macademia says no House of macademia is
basically a company that figured out a
way to Corner the market they work with
over 90 South African farmers and um
I've been harassing the owner that
handsome bastard I've been harassing I
go dude all I do is drink black coffee
you need to melt milk those nuts well
you don't want milk in your coffee
sometimes like dairy milk and Macadamia
milk is so thick and it tastes that's a
real thing macadamia nut milk well House
of macadamia is he giving away a free
gallon of macadamia milk yeah and it's
100% macadamia nuts 100% And it's free
with any order there's no added sugars
oils are stabiliz you can order the 45%
macadamia nut bars the Macadamia
chocolate covered nuts and you get a g g
gallon of macademia milk when you visit
House of macadamias decom sltf a just
add the milk to your cart with any
products and you use the code
TFK that's a gallon of macademia nut
milk enjoy delicious nutties hello sir
what's up you handsome bastard you're on
the air with me and Brian Ken oh my God
I'm so nervous don't worry dude I'm a
regular guy taller in person more
athletic but a regular guy I promise
he's going to look a little older he's
it's like a catfish you think that
they're hot looking and then you see
them in person like oh wow their eyes
are off yeah he's a little don't tell me
any jokes or I won't be able to focus
sorry man yeah man but uh we wanted to
call you cuz we're idiots and uh you
know this whole Ian Gary drama this mess
here what exactly is going on cuz before
you give your expert Insight on this and
you know this what's going on here is my
whole thing is Ian Gary's wife is
obviously spare heading this whole PR
his social media she's doing an awful
job and she's turned Ian Gary into the
most hated man in the UFC but then off a
lot of it's a troll job so it's tough to
tell what's real what what's legit so
that's why we have you here what's going
on with this whole Ian Gary stuff all
right so I guess where I would start
would be to say that anything that has
happened for Ian Gary in the last week
since this thing blew up is exceptional
for his career assuming that he can keep
it focused and he doesn't care about
people talking [__] and calling him a
cuck because I mean you know as well as
me we can measure a person's
pay-per-view draw ability based on the
views that we get if we put a video up
about him and this guy's this guy is
officially a person I can do videos
about that people will click on now he's
a star yeah good you know what I mean
but like as far as this actual thing I
can't I can't really
tell if if it's if it's completely
staged that would that would surprise me
you know it's like
I I think that the the idea that she is
a predatory girl who like who saw Ian
Gary and she was like I'm gonna trap
this [__] with a kid I'm gonna
take all of his money and that's what
it's gonna be it's probably a stretch
given the fact that he was the cage
Warriors champion at the time I mean
like he had a that's a big that's a big
reach that's a big reach first of all
it's a reach and also Ian Gary is an
attractive man with a future but but you
know he's also an MMA fighter that if
she wanted to chase a if she was a gold
digger she'd chase a soccer player she
have chased a a premier league guy for
her to bank on a a young Ian Gary who's
a cage Warriors champ I mean she she's
in the wrong business she should she
should be a man water at all she just
obviously is attracted to him and and
loves the guy go on Jess sorry no no
yeah no I'm with you guys I mean it's
like it's it's like it's it's a
salacious story especially when the the
the thing came out that she had written
this thing how to be a wag you know wife
and girlfriend but as she explained and
then I further verified yesterday she
was like first of all the how to be a
wag for anybody who didn't know it's
it's like w wag means wife and
girlfriend and it's a it's a term that
characterizes like uh Victoria Beckham
or someone who is like a rich socialite
married to a baller ass football player
in the UK right so
when I looked into it what she said is
she's like first of all that was written
in 2010 and it was a [__] joke she's
like I work for Okay magazine and it was
a joke satire when you really like when
you look at it it's it is I mean it
seems to me it's clearly satire and the
other thing too is she got married after
2010 to a dude who's neither a football
player nor rich like in between writing
the book and Ian Gary so it's like you
know when I covered on the Chann I'll
make it kind of like funny and entertain
all angles but if you're you know if
someone's seriously like dude do you
think that she trappy and Gary and dirty
it's like no no no I don't but Jess do
do you think part of the reason they're
doing this is you know how it goes I
mean I know how this goes when you when
you have a lot of haters they're going
to look for these rumors and this stuff
to try to disparage you and come up with
stuff so I think his hate got so bad
that it went down this road
unfortunately for him they it to put the
these pieces of the
that bad though yeah yeah that's fair
the other thing too is like because it
everybody now is like scouring the
internet looking for stuff that they can
pile on here and it's like the it's like
it it it resembles the Nina agall and
Logan Paul thing but the thing about the
nah agall and Logan Paul thing is nah is
way more famous than she was and also
had put out so much content like it was
part of her brand that she's like I can
swallow a 12in [__] that's part of my
brand she tried to represent herself oh
I wouldn't sleep with Logan when we
first started dating it's like she knows
there are a bunch of [__] hand
grenades that can blow up in her face at
any time and D [__] dug them all up
sure did a different situation can can I
just tell that what is there to hate
about I'm just saying what is there to
hate about Ian Gary and his wife this a
bigger story but you know what I'm
saying like he got a lot of hate the way
no it's not though he got a lot of hate
because the way he was acting he's doing
an impression of Conor start he when he
beat Neil Magny the way he went about it
seeing Neil Magny beats his kids he made
a a shirt of a mug shot got it got it he
so he Brian just found out who Ian Gary
is before he started the show no i' i' I
know he is I just didn't know I know he
was kind of it was weird with the Neil
Magny thing I remember that I was like I
was puzzled by that but um you talk
about Jeff Neil or I'm saying Neil the
Neil Magny fight he gotu that cuz he's
flipping Neil off and then the Jeff Neil
especially with the mug shot but again I
think this goes back what him and his
wife do I don't I don't know why anybody
gives a [__] about that stuff but when
it comes to the way she's handling his
PR it's atrocious dude that's my issue
with her I don't care about anything
else but it's like you have this kid who
you and I were texting uh this morning
if I had to bet on anybody to be world
champion 12 to 18 months my money's on
Gary that kid's so [__] talented dude
he's going to beat bente luk hopefully
if he gets past this [__] storm and then
the fight between him and Leon Edwards
that's a pretty [__] possible thing
in the next 12 months man well yeah
because you had the but you had all the
[__] about Leon Edwards and them kicking
him out of the gym there's a narrative
there thing about that and then now now
because of this whole thing with the c
now the one thing that we are leaving
out is the fact that the ex-husband her
ex-husband lives with them supposedly I
don't want to get hit with a defamation
charge if he like lives next door see I
I heard that's I heard that's not true I
heard that's one of the fake things
again I don't know what to believe he
definitely is his nutritionist that's
for sure that's a nightmare then no it's
not that just means that Ian Gary's
confident enough to have the xes now
Jesse that's one cuck explaining cuck
moves Brian's a cuck I got no problem
with it that's the biggest cuck move if
you're if you're if the ex-husband's
living with you nah it's fine that's CU
[__] come on hey I'll have my coffee
with a little cream come on it's fine
little caveat here Brian also drives a
Tesla so tread
lightly you i'mot like about that is no
matter how overconfident you are you are
an MMA fighter it is 100% inevitable
that you're going to be traveling at
times by yourself and your wife is not
going to be with you and your
nutritionist might not be with you in
which case if you get in a fight with
your [__] wife who is a hard [__]
tent she is a smoke dude f smoke leave
her alone with her a dude who's been in
that living in your house and he's
already done God damn it that's so hot I
mean that's so worrying sorry Brian's
all about it Brian's looking for a
nutritionist right now as long as you
get a video Brian's looking for a black
nutritionist right now well as long as
he's a professional athlete be black
could be L 11 in deep yeah dude we'll
see if it fits a criteria yeah I just
want to reach out to you and get the to
see what's going on here but again I
think all this blows over literally
everyone forgets about it if he head
kicks vente luk into the [__] third
row I absolutely agree and I think he's
going to if you look at like the because
he did a he did a video yesterday where
he essentially was just directing people
to her Instagram story because she was
explaining the wag book which I I would
say that's the only thing like the only
thing she should put a statement out was
about the wag book because if any smart
person looks at what she said and then
looks at the book it's like okay yeah
it's probably a [__] joke yeah I
don't think she should say anything else
about this whatsoever agree but when but
when Ian Gary was like you think she's
not going to say anything he's like
you're you're out of your mind he was
chilling like you could tell she just
was like could you direct
people he doesn't look like he's
tripping at all like he looks completely
focused which makes me even more
confident well that's a mindset of a
world champion my man that that makes me
like him even more yeah me too Jesse you
got to come on the podcast sometime
starts in practice though when he was in
Florida and I found out who it was and
I'm just juggling whether or not I'm
gonna put that info out oh I'll talk to
you off air about that yeah I know I
like [__] I hate feeling like I'm piling
on people but it's like it's a pretty
[__] big scoop we're talking about
practice though we're talking about
practice talking about practice 100% I
don't care about any of that stuff but I
I do think that kid has a a chance to be
world champion I think this is going to
earn him more fans especially if he
handles it the right way and doesn't Len
listen to his wife dude every single
thing that's bad on your way up
immediately becomes a positive if you
kick the living [__] out of everybody
corre every just like damn they
weathered that storm and then perform
like that as as David said just win baby
that's allado needs to do and I probably
drop drop her last name from your yours
whatever that's that's nor here nor
there but uh we we appreciate you
brother I'll hit you up after this but
you're you're my go-to on this stuff man
because I it's hard for me to keep up
I'm old fair enough you call me anytime
sir all right brother Jesse I'll call
you every day buddy just to talk yeah
all right brother we'll see you soon man
appreciate you
later this isn't a pouch this is a pouch
what's up guys if you're like me I used
to use white nicotine pouches all the
time non-stop whatever it was if you saw
me on podcast your boy had it in if you
saw me on stage I had it in if I'm at
the gym I had nicotine in my mouth at
all times and then I found black Buffalo
they make the same great flavors that
you know we're talking about mint winter
green they got my favorite the straight
and they're all tobacc free that means
no tobacco stem or Leaf is in these and
they're made in the US OFA us of a
product so you know it's good it's black
Buffalo so if you're 21 or older and you
use nicotine or tobacco head on over to
Black Buffalo that's black buffalo.com
Jesse on fire Jesse on fire that's
awesome I was going to chime in to say
to ask Jesse but it's fine that we what
you say Jen did he listen to the actual
Audi book yeah that's what he said he
actually no he didn't no that's what he
said he goes if you actually listen to
it but I wanted to ask him straight up
did you actually listen to the AUD book
because he said though CH he goes if
anybody who listens to it iist can't
take it Ser but and you think it's real
you want to listen to it we can do it
right now we can fast forward afterwards
we don't have time for that that's what
I'm saying so you didn't listen to it I
did hey I lived it but uh so there's
actual tips to being a wag she even
brings in like freaking like makeup
artist all the stuff like I listen she
didn't put it into practice what she
didn't put she she married she married a
civilian after here here's the M main
thing is like of course it's all stupid
and we shouldn't even be in like going
into Ian Gary's Life with this girl
whatever but I get the fact that Sean
Strickland saying like he shouldn't have
done it publicly he should have done it
privately like you said yeah if you want
to if you actually want to help him you
should be like hey dude just
so say when people say she's saying
she's defending herself like it's
satirical if you listen to it it's not
satirical yeah I don't know well that's
that's a that's a matter of opinion
that's my opinion I would love people to
actually listen to the there's a there's
a five minute preview on Amazon if you
want to listen to it and for yourself
that's all right I don't know you wanted
me to dive deeper so I dive deeper yeah
no I'm glad you did CH yeah that's the
thing who know but I think it it make
her look worse if she released that wag
and then married like a Premier League
soccer player right but she releases
that and then marries a even then I got
no problem but she couldn't get it maybe
she could get you might also remember
the the com out story I told you about
right that Ian Gary himself put out
there agree I think we're in agree with
this
I and it works for them which more power
to him then that's fine let yeah let's
get relationship but but I I do think
she's the butt of all his issues I don't
think she's good for him yeah but who
knows may maybe professionally for them
that's fine that's fine but I'm saying
he's still ranked what number seven in
the world some and I like even getting
into their business kind of sucks but
this is like the biggest Topic in you
know the May world so we The Real
Housewives yep but yeah it's interesting
though yeah it is you have TR you'd have
trouble fighting at 70 I know you're on
board cuck boy
what whatever are your favorite fighter
now [__] yes he's so talented too he's
so talented stupid talented but again
this gets way worse for him if he goes
in and loses in De was it December 10th
the next pay-per-view If he if he goes
out there and loses in Vegas then then
this becomes a bigger story if he head
kicks Vicente luk we don't give a [__]
yeah you May 16th it's the it's the nth
oh oh no it's December 16th and we're
doing a fight campaign for that we have
Ian Gary's wife
on we have Ian Gary's wife and Sean
Strickland together that should be at
that yeah that should be interesting I
miss Sean vent number 10 versus number
eight wow that's yeah it's a tough fight
well there we go you also have Patty
piml and Tony Ferg on the same card I
love that fight you love it not me you
want to bet on that and I'm a huge Patty
piml fan Patty's one my favorite fighter
Tony to retire yeah but it's not how
he's [__] fighting Brian you want to
bet on it no no why uh I don't want to
bet on an old horse who used to be great
I'm betting on Tony no are you I want
Tony yes you think Tony's gonna win that
fight yes because I know why you think
Tony's gonna win that fight CU David
gogins no David gogins oh I would love
to take that bet then bet you think Tony
gives a flying [__] if you bet against
him no not at all I would I'm saying I
don't like betting against Tony because
you're gonna lose no I'm taking Tony
yeah oh that's crazy ad $1,000 a th000
American dollars all due respect to the
great Tony Ferguson I'm taking that
betet I yeah I mean he's Underdog yeah
yeah I'll take you David goggin's
trained he made through David's hell
week the only only athlete too right to
make it through it be in great shape
yeah Tony Ferguson's is not about a sh
never point it was never his don't be
wrong is it the best bet no I like you I
like where you're at I like that you're
feeling a little reckless and I like
that you're putting your I don't know
Pat I the good thing is if you're a
Patty fan which I am is he's had a long
layoff he's been able to train and work
on things but from going from his last
fight to the I I I think Tony can do is
if he doesn't get clipped and you know
and obviously Patty doesn't have the
best striking so I like I like Tony's
chances yeah yeah well we'll see so Bren
quick question on that
so uh so Patty even said publicly like
it's a lose lose for him yeah I agree
with that right so if you were in a
position like with Patty would you think
the same thing like it's a lose lose
would you want to fight still I mean you
you're going to take the fight cuz
Tony's a is a good feather in the cap
even though he's lost seven in a row so
it I agree with Patty doesn't make a ton
of sense right cuz if you beat Tony like
all right this his eth lot loss in a row
you know if you lose to him it's like
you just lost to a guys lost seven in a
row for [__] I'm with Patty on this it's
not a lot of upside
M if you go to if it's a war it's like
fight of the Year people like yeah he's
lost seven a row dude way to go if you
beat him like way to go so I don't think
we learn a lot from Patty in this you go
out there and starch him it's not about
how much better Patty's gotten it's
about how bad Tony is Tony's getting a
Payday still right I mean of course yeah
he's probably one of the higher paid
yeah been in so long so Tony's a plus
240 Draft Kings yeah there's no upside
for Patty in this if he wins oh you beat
a a weathered Tony Ferguson if you lose
it's a nightmare if you starch him
people like who cares it's Tony fergon
lost seven in a row so we we won't know
but it is a good adversity to put Patty
through that's a big name it's like yeah
know it's a big yeah there's someu P's
bigger name in some ways right some some
circles like up and cominging big names
for sure yeah not in America but in in
the UK not close he's the fifth Beetle
y it's good fight though
yeah what what I was just thinking about
how he goes my my dog took a huge crap
on
your are you Pat of the bat I am yeah
yeah cleans it up my dog took a cacious
huge crap on their lawn he's
so he's such a nice guy the whole like
uh since you know the whole Sam thing do
you think that was planned or no what
that part no you think that was like a
no I I'm just curious I'm just curious
he just I think that was natural good
guy yeah P's a great guy yep damn only
18 days only 18 days that's the ring
door camera oh you want want to see it
again or no no all
right he's all bundled up hear what he
says all right dog sloppy
[__] hello look it's the dogs just had
like a sloppy [__] outside I was just
wondering if he got some water I don't
want to leave it
outside it is I'm five minutes away from
him and don't worry I'll clean
it you sure I just I feel I feel
terrible know what I mean no Sor just
had the prop sloppy [__] and I can't
even pick it up with the poo bag know
what I mean don't worry I'll clean it
when had a proper
poo bag you know what I mean sorry about
that I ha doing stuff like that that's
why I'm not go on see you
later is that a sloppy [__] is that a
sloppy [__] sloppy [__] sloppy [__] I
feel bad I've got no poags I feel bad so
[__] that part of the world is so
violent it's like the the the so you you
know what redneck culture like when you
call when you talk about rednecks right
like in the Appalachian mountains and
they all came from that part of they
were all Brit English and Irish and
Scottish herders they it was herd like
herd culture and its honor culture and
that's why they fought they would fight
pitbulls you know when they you're
breeding dogs for fighting it came from
that region they're a [__] rough
Bunch that's what they do that's what
they do if they don't have guns either
so they they solve the problems through
fighting knives andov yeah here here
we'll shoot
you
Bots
Bots oh only fans model claim she had a
threeesome with okay so the only reason
why this popped up is because so the
during the whole Ian Gary um and his
wife drama yeah um apparently I saw that
Dylan danis posted like some DMS that
him and Ian Garry's before he was he was
married with his wife like him and his
wife were you know chatting back and
forth it's nothing crazy though okay uh
you know I'm not going to show those cuz
I kind of want to get over it but
anyways so I I Googled Dy Dylan D danis
after that and it says this only F only
fans model said that she had a threesome
with danis before the Logan Paul fight
and she's like smoking hot let's see um
and this is apparently someone's saying
this about danis that Logan
posted anyway I'll just show you the
girl she was on a podcast and saids she
had like a a threesome with Dylan Dennis
and this is the girl what's up Jesus
Christ
she said he was so worried that Logan
sent her yeah he thought it was like a
trap kind of thing so maybe he wasn't as
comfortable as it should have been but
they still had he said that she said
that they boned first and they boned
again after the third person showed up
but uh this girl is like it's good to be
Dylan
danis yep does he really think Dylan
does he really think Logan was like I
can't stand this guy let's send this
actually smoke show and have a threesome
good luck in the fight well you know
yeah anyway yeah she's cool when you do
I know now I know when you say she's
cool I know exactly talking
about um I leave it at that she's cool
all right she cool she cool she cool she
cool baby I also think Logan Paul sent
all the ladies to talk to me yep that's
right if Logan doesn't like you he he
requires you to
bust oh yeah I'm going sent a smoke show
to your room got another girl mared
Logan I said I I said first rule is you
don't Sue you got so upset do something
about it yeah send this absolute smoke
show for a thre
sub how dare you how very dare you um
all right so this was actually caz's
current event from Monday but we didn't
talk about it but so Derek shovin yeah
one of the cops that was involved in the
Floyd you know George Floyd yeah he's
the one to put KN on his neck so he was
he was stabbed in prison and uh I guess
people that are in prison are saying
like he's not going to last long he's
going to oh hell yeah yeah of course
yeah you know um the I don't know if you
saw but the coroner didn't the coroner
with the autopsy uh hid the fact that he
was on he might have died for other
reasons he might have died from fentanyl
he had a bunch of stuff in his system
and that's a very interesting thing I'm
sure his lawyers a Hot Topic lawyers are
like wait a
minute there was a corner who was
involved in it who brought that up and
he goes no I don't want to talk about it
he goes it's above my pay grade y she's
like no but there's all this stuff in
his system
that could have elevated things where he
would have not been able to breathe
that's clearly something that his
lawyers I'm sure are all over oh they
but I mean the reality is the cop was
the cop the cop was doing a a terrible
thing of like just leaving his leg on
there but as far as like the death the
the true cause of death yeah I'm pretty
sure people can go but then again would
he have died if he didn't have if he
hadn't been panicked and and
claustrophobic too you know with a with
a knee on your neck right for that long
so it's it's tough but it's tough are
you sending me something or no it's
tough oh okay the whole thing's dicey
all right so this is a uh that was a
weird time in America yeah and it's it's
just so it's so complicated there's so
many things there's so many yeah so yeah
it's not that complicated but it's just
a weird no I'm saying like to discuss
exactly you know what I'm saying black
and white no intended I knew a guy was
saying I knew a guy was saying look you
we're we're under lockdowns right
everybody's wearing masks he said try
saying that the black lives matter
protests spread covid nobody was going
to say that it nobody was going to say
well wait a minute we have all these
people very obvious you weren't allowed
to Pro you weren't allowed to protest
anything else but if it was black lives
matter you could protest yeah it's very
we could say anything otherwise you get
canc I'll get a better one the the the
left has this idea that if you if you
feel like a woman you're allowed to say
that I'm a woman and you have to call me
you have to refer to me as she okay
because I have an inner feeling a woman
is an inner feeling okay now I can't say
though I'm
black I'm
transracial even though I might have
actually 5% subsaharan African or
something in me I'm not allowed to say
that so apparently
chromosomes are not relevant irant but
melanin talking about science right now
does matter like you're talking about
legit science yeah no man they don't
want to hear that but you can say you're
yeah they don't want to hear science but
you're supposed to trust the science I
thought trust the science but hold on
but you're saying so if you're saying I
can't by the
same argument I could say I'm
transracial but apparently I can't do
that I can't say I'm black can't say I'm
a woman mhm but they told me to trust
the science with the vaccine I'm just
saying youy you trying get us
demonetized right now man just saying
these are not the views how come I can't
follow this
it's really interesting you're making
too much sense and I got to shut up
because I'll never understand but then
silence is violence this is really
interesting but going back to the the
whole BLM Pro test remember I was
telling you guys I never wanted to own a
gun I always thought like I can whatever
if something happened I'll just you know
do whatever your techniques no not my
techniques but I'm saying like chines
whatever okay whatever but during the
the BLM protests how did it benefit me
and people around me you know what
happened during the be I was living in
Downtown LA I even filmed it and put on
my Vlogs I'm pretty sure I showed you
guys yeah they're crashing Windows
stealing looting what how the hell is
that helping anything dude that was the
that's what I saw personally yeah that's
what Trump says if they start looting we
start shooting my girlfriend at the time
she was stay with staying with me so
she's freaking out the entire are they
going to come to the apartment I'm like
[__] I have to get a gun now yeah so
that's why I got a gun yeah I use num
trucks but yeah I use my bare
hair what's this J I was so just
apparently every now and then there's
some crazy stuff that happens in
airplanes so this woman was in I think
in Louisiana some dude just jumped out
of the
plane I thought you couldn't open it no
this is I think after they landed yeah
so he just like bouncing afterwards and
then uh they they filmed it I think the
video is the more funnier part I'd
rather see him open it but
yeah hold on that's the end of it here's
how it begins go y'all go
y'all Z are you okay what what happened
he put something on the plane and jumped
off
the so imagine someone jumps off a plane
when you're departing you're thinking
probably there's a bomb or something
right Panic some people get so
claustrophobic they go
crazy oh they di there he is there he is
there he that that's a security guard
trying to catch him he fell there he is
there he is right and then he tried to
steal this truck at the airport no there
he ISO they got him
thank
god oh my god well he jumped out of the
plane he just so he jumped out before
like the ramp the the stairs came I
think as soon as it so high up it's
already it's so high you and they Tred
to steal the truck I was thinking about
those stairs going that would really
hurt oh it's so high up god dog
um we should probably stop after this
one right yeah all right so this is the
last one so Andrew huberman was on ha's
podcast and YouTube channel and Andrew
huberman Dr Andrew hubman who's like
very popular on YouTube he's been on
Rogan he's never shown his tattoos or
his body he always like feels like
jacked yeah cuz he's like a a Stanford
Professor he just doesn't want people to
like think about jacked scientist I get
it so now in this video you can see how
jacked he is mental 10
system almost dropped it right there
there's more for Brian not setting this
thing down Andrew human and he's and
he's tatted up too he's a professor and
smart I think Wicked smart Wicked smart
yeah big boy too about 62 I
think was like Gordon Ryan yeah he's
thick yeah see Gordon Ryan shaved his
beard yep I'm he looks so innocent now
yeah looks great well yeah so huberman
is love it Hub and and both jacked hu M
nothing better than a jacked
man
guys I'm in Chicago next Friday Saturday
Chicago downtown Chicago tell me where
to get your deep dish cast rolls that's
December 8th and 9th two shows Friday
two shows Saturday Nashville's January
25th one show only then Austin I'm off
the Austin that Friday Saturday January
26 27th Austin Texas get your ticket at
thick
boy.com guys good news December 7 8 and9
helium Indianapolis Indiana Spokane
Comedy Club December 1516 off the Comedy
Club December 21 22 23 in Naples Florida
and finally I ring in the New Year in
Charlotte North Carolina Comedy Zone
come see me that's all I got to say I'm
going to London God bless you all right
kids love you